hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today is week two of the month-long
extravaganza if you want to call it
today is gonna be on the heat so kiri
version and that's going to be lasting
throughout this current week with the
your event going next week and these on
who event being the final week of the
month and then we get to start getting
into the juicier stuff within the year
and hopefully getting that new season
and seeing other details like that but
today's topic is gonna be all about the
heat so kiri event shadow of the heat so
kiri what came in it what is going to
stay what is not staying and anything
and all those other details like that so
as long as like the be if you do enjoy
subscribe if we knew I covered the
informational sada fauna that being the
balance changes the here updates the pet
shots and the leaks if you want to be
kept it today with everything happening
at than the roller for honor and never
miss hello I don't update definitely
stay subscribe the channel
alright that let's get started with
today's video so like I said in the
intro we're gonna be going over the hito
kiri version of this month-long
extravaganza and as always we're gonna
be going over what is in the current
event right now as I know some older
players may have forgotten and then some
newer players who just joined us for
year four have no idea what's in this
event so first we're gonna be going over
things that made it from the original to
the remake and then the things that had
got lost in the process first up though
is the ornaments and in specific this is
going to be categorized in the lootable
section so first up we have the
ornaments like I stated now the footage
you're seeing from this is in all the
video of mine and you're gonna be seeing
text in the top right there or in the
top left or whatever it says lootable
buyable like I said we're gonna be going
over that in a bit but these are gonna
be the ornaments as you're seeing on
screen obviously these are going to be
faction specific ornaments which if you
don't understand what that means that
means it is the same general premise of
each of the ornaments as you can tell
there's a face with in the middle of
roughly all of them but these smaller
intricate details are different
depending on the faction that you wear
it for next up is the battle outfit this
is a black and white kind of style to it
this is only going to be available for
the next week so definitely get it
quickly as where some of these other
things we'll be talking about later are
have been available for the past year so
they really don't have anything to do
with this upcoming event currently but
this in specific you need to get within
the week or it's never coming back and
then lastly for the lootable stuff is
the effect
and of course this comes in idle
execution in emote form but if you
really want to get all of them you're
going to have to grind a little bit more
than you think as at the end of every
match it might say Nisha and then the
effect with it
and that doesn't necessarily mean it's
going to be the all three of the
versions it's just going to be one of
the three pick randomly so if you want
to get all three of them you're gonna
have to grind a little bit more as like
I said all three come separately and if
you've done a bunch of events you know
this is the case for every single event
so obviously if you just want one of
them makes your job easier but if you
want to collect all three of them you're
gonna have to get grinding a bit more
than you think all things that we just
talked about are considered lootable
which means all you have to do is play
matches and get lucky you don't need to
play a warden to get the warden effects
as it is just random so all you have to
do is keep playing those matches and
pray to rngesus about with steel first
is the mask outfits of course these are
different perfection this is also
following a similar trend of not
actually being a mask outfit which is
how I got the name illustrious outfit
this is gonna have this weird kind of
ghosty guy in the back behind you of
course if this is anything like last
week these should be discounted to about
13,000 steel but if it's not discounted
it should be the regular 20,000 steel as
usual and it also really doesn't matter
in particular to this current event as
this mask outfit has existed even after
the event ended last year so you could
still get it within the week if you
don't want to get it within the week you
can wait till next month next year it's
gonna be here till the end of time so
there's no rush something that isn't
though is the emote this is also viable
and this is something interesting of
some sort of possession emotes and I
believe once again if trends continue if
it is discounted it should be 7000 steel
but if it is not discounted the original
price is 10,000 this will go away after
the week so you should definitely get
this immediately before you can't
anymore lastly is the weapons these have
a nice little silver tone to it kind of
like last week but these have more of a
reddish vibe to it as well so if that's
your fancy definitely pick these up the
characters assigned to the weapon is
going to be on screen for you to see and
these are also considered lootable but
it's a little bit different as we talked
about before with the effects those are
considered lootable at random these are
more specific for the hero you play so
if you want to get Shaolin you have to
play Shaolin for the matches just like
any other normal match or for honor when
you finish a game you're gonna be
getting weapon parts and stuff for that
specific character you finished the
match with this is no different so if
you want to get Shaolin gear you have to
play Shaolin for the weapons
specifically if it has to do with the
effects remember that's just anybody in
it's random RNG and while the weapons
show off I do want to do one quick
little final send-off to the content
coming back remember in the original
timeline that these events actually came
out last year
every hero buds on who and your existed
at this time we had no idea who your
mores on who was so only those heroes
will get the effects weapons etc if
you're playing is on who in your don't
as you won't get anything from this
event for them specifically you of
course can still play them if you just
want to grind the hero or maybe get
those lootable effects for the other
heroes as like I stated that's all RNG
based but if you're trying to get the
stuff for them you know the purchasable
steel things are trying to get their
weapons I would highly recommend against
it as they do not have any weapons for
this event so it's pretty much pointless
now that that is done we can now talk
about what is not coming back and the
first part is gonna be the minions and
the backer on main menu of course if
trends continue from last week I made in
my last video and I said in the black
prior event that the minions and the
main menu music had returned and the
screen had also returned I was actually
a little bit wrong as I made that video
a day before just as this video is
actually being recorded at Wednesday
night to go up Thursday afternoon at
least within my time zone so because
obviously this stuff is already old so
I'm just kind of relooking at the info
from last year and making the video
ahead of time obviously I had no idea
that the minions and the main menu music
was not coming back so I do apologize
for that but of course of trends
continue those two things should also
not continue for this event so it's
gonna be normal minions and the normal
year for season 1 background on top of
that the new game mode for that event
was also not returning that was I forgot
the actual specific name for it but it
had a weird kind of different idea for a
game mode very unique and personally my
favorite actually it was where you would
kill minions and kill players and
capture their souls
per se and then take those points and/or
souls and deposit them in specific areas
around the map and that's how you got
points to win the game and of course it
was on the new map canopy at the time
which was a really cool looking map this
has been replaced with dance of death
which is the 2v2 equivalent of carousel
of death and of course the original
version is dance of death a 2v2 mode
where you and your teammate have to kill
the opposing player at the same exact
time before the round actually counts
and if it doesn't happen then you
respawn yeah that's good to be
everything about the shadow of the heat
so carry event going on this week of
course stay tuned for the next couple
days as I will have a video in between
this and the next event video to kind of
hold you guys off as we have a nice
little hero concept so we did a little
sneak peek if you've made it to the end
of this video it's gonna be another hero
concepts video super excited to upload
this one is we got some really nice
ideas coming but yeah then we have that
then we have the Jorma vent and then the
Zhan who event and then we're gonna have
a lot of different videos in between
those and hopefully we'll get some see
information on the year for season 2
stuff as I'm super excited to see what's
coming in the game but what that like to
be if you do enjoy guys subscribe if
you're new I covered the informational
side a foreigner that being the balance
changes the hero updates the Patchett's
and the leaks if you want to be kept up
to date with everything happening within
the world before honor I never miss out
on an update definitely stay subscribe
the channel with that take care guys
have a gross today I'd be so
[Music]
you